okay sure um in the 60s you you found he
was 68 was it you you founded this
magazine Bravo oh the original one
that's hard to find that's right
issue one right why did that make so
much impact counterculture was the main
event that I was part of at the time and
it was made up of hippies and new left
that was sort of my contemporaries the
people are just slightly older than and
my mode is to look at where the flow the
interesting flow is and then look the
other direction uh-huh
partly I was trained to do that as an
army officer but partly it's just a
cheap heuristic to find the originality
is don't look where everybody else is
looking look the opposite way so they
deal with the counterculture is the
hippies were very romantic kind of
against technology they accept very good
LSD from Sandoz and the New Left was
against technology because they thought
it was a power device computers were do
now it's bindle fold or mutilate you
know fight that and so all if catalog
was kind of a counter counter culture
thing in the sense that I bought
buckminster fuller's idea that tools are
of the essence scientists and engineers
basically define the world in the
interesting ways if all the politicians
disappeared one week it would be a
nuisance but if all the scientists and
engineers disappeared one week it would
be way more than a nuisance so we so
believe that I think so focus on that
and then the new left was talking about
power to people and then people like
Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak cut that
and just said power to people tools that
actually work and so where Fuller was
saying don't try to change human nature
people in trying for a long time and it
does not even Bend you can change tools
very easily so the efficient thing to do
if you want to make the world better
he's not trying to make people behave
differently like the new left was but
just give them tools that go in the
right direction that was the whole
catalog and this is the sexual image of
this is one of the first images the
first time people have seen Earth from
outer space that had an impact too it
was a kind of a chance that in the
spring of 66 thanks to an LSD experience
on a rooftop in San Francisco I got
thinking about against something that
Fuller talked about is that a lot of
people assume that the earth is flat
kind of infinite terms of its resources
but once you really grasp that it's a
sphere and then that there's only so
much of it then you start husbanding
your resources and thinking about it as
a finite system spaceship earth was his
metaphor and I wanted that to be the
case but on LSD I was getting higher and
higher on my hundred micrograms on the
roof of San Francisco and noticed that
the downtown buildings which were right
in front of me were we're not all
parallel they were sort of stand out
like this and that's because they are on
a curved surface and if I were even
higher I would see that even more
clearly higher than that see it more
clearly still higher enough and it would
close and you would get the circle of
Earth from space and I thought you know
we've been in space for ten years at
that time this is 66 and the cameras had
never looked back they'd always been
looking out or don't looking at just
parts of the earth so I said what no did
a button why don't we see a photograph
of the whole earth yet and it went
around and NASA got it and Senator his
secretaries got it and various people in
the Politburo got it and went on and
within two and a half years above the
time the whole earth catalogue came out
these images started to appear and
indeed they did transform everything and
it's my idea of hacking civilization is
that you tried to do something lazy and
ingenious and just sort of trick the
situation so all these photographs you
see even the March does science last
week they're occurring these you know
horth banners and so on I did that with
no work
I sold for 25 cents apiece so you know
the tweaking the system I think not only
the most efficient way to make
system go in interesting ways but in
some ways the safest way because when
you try to horse the whole system around
in a big way you can get into big horse
around problems but if you tweak it
it'll adjust to you the tweet so I mean
since since then among many other things
you've been regarded as a leading voice
in the environmental movement but you
are also a counterculture list and and
recently you've been taking on a lot of
well you've been declaring what a lot of
environmentalists almost believe of
heresies and I couldn't want to explore
a couple of those I mean tell me about
this image here haha that's a National
Geographic image of what the is called
the mammoth step the far north of Arctic
and Arctic region used to look like in
fact the whole world used to look like
that
but we find in South African Serengeti
now of lots of big animals was the case
in this part of Canada throughout the
u.s. throughout Eurasia throughout the
world these this was the norm and can be
again so in a sense by the long-term
goal at this point is to not only bring
back those animals in the grassland they
made which is part of could be a climate
stabilization system over the long run
but even the Manas there in the
background that a part of the story and
I think that's probably a 200 year Cole
maybe in 100 by the end of the century
we should be able to dial down the
extinction rates you sort of what it's
been in the background bringing back
this amount of bio abundance will take
longer but it's what it's doing well
we'll come back to the mammoths but but
I mean explain how we should think of
extinctions there's obviously one of the
huge concerns right now is that
extinction is happening at a faster rate
you know than ever in history but that's
the that's the meme that's out there how
should we think of it the story is out
there is that were in the middle of the
sixth extinction or maybe at the
beginning of the sixth extinction
because we're in the de-extinction
business that preventing extinction
business with ver five members we're
looking at you know actually going on
with the extinction and turns out is a
very
confused so data out there which gets
oversimplified into the narrative of
where we're becoming here of five mass
extinctions that are indicated by the
yellow triangles and we're now next the
last one there on the far right was the
meteor that struck 66 million years ago
and did it in the dinosaurs and the
story is where the next meteor well
here's the deal I went up researching
this for a paper I wrote that a mass
extinction is when 75% of all of species
and the world go extinct well is on the
order of five and a half million species
of which we've identified one and a half
million another fourteen thousand are
being identified every year a lot of
biology going on out there since 1500
about 500 species not extinct and you'll
see the term mass extinction kind of
used in strange ways so there was a year
and a half ago a front-page story by
Carl Zimmer in the New York Times mass
extinction the oceans broaden studies
show and you read into the article and
it mentions that since 1515 species 1/5
have gone extinct in the oceans and oh
by the way none in the last 50 years you
read further into the story and is
saying a horrifying thing is going on is
that the fisheries are so over hunting
overfishing the wild fish is that it is
taking down the fish population in the
oceans like by 38 percent that's the
serious thing
none of those species are probably going
to go extinct so you've just put that
headline writer put a panic button on
the top of the story its clickbait kind
of stuff but it's basically saying oh my
god start panicking we're gonna lose all
the species in the oceans nothing like
that is in Prospect and in fact what
then I started looking into a little
more details the red list shows about
23,000 species that are considered
threatened at one level or another
coming from the there's actually Union
the Conservation of Nature IUCN and
nature magazine had a piece kind of
surveying loss of wildlife and it said
if all of those 23,000 went extinct in
the next century or so and that rate of
extinction carried on for more centuries
in millennia then we might be at the
beginning of a six exchange hunt
so the exaggeration is way out hand but
confirm Ellis awe is exaggerated that's
a problem I mean they probably feel like
a moral responsibility because they care
so much about the thing that they are
looking at and unless you bang the drum
for it maybe no innocence every time
somebody says moral this or moral that
moral hazard precautionary principle
these are trends that are used to
basically say no so the problem isn't so
much fish extinction animal extinction
is fish flourishing animal flourishing
that where it were crowding them to
something step yeah and I think that's
the we are crowding and there is losses
going on the major losses are caused by
agriculture and so anything that
improves agriculture and basically makes
it more condensed more highly productive
including GMOs please if you want to do
it vertical farms and town including
inside farms all the things they've been
learning about how to pro pot in
basements is now being applied to
growing vegetables inside containers
that's great that's all good stuff
because land sparing is the main thing
we can do for nature people moving to
cities is good
making agriculture at less of a
destruction on the landscape there's
been and there are people talking about
bringing back species rewilding well
festival rewarding species and what's
the story with these guys Oh Walt Europe
sneaking you the previous point where
now it probably piqued farmland and by
the way in terms of population we are
already at peak children being alive
henceforth there will be fewer and fewer
children we are in the last doubling of
human population and it will get to nine
maybe nine and a half billion and then
start not just leveling off we're
probably going down
likewise farmland is now
Peke and one of the ways that plays out
in Europe is there's a lot of abandoned
farmland now which immediately forests
they don't do wildlife corridors in
Europe they don't need to because so
many of these farms are connected that
they've made reforested wildlife
corridors that the wolves are coming
back in this case to Spain they've
gotten all the way to the Netherlands
there's bears coming back there's links
coming back there's a European jackal I
had no idea such a thing existed they're
coming back from Italy to the rest of
Europe and unlike here these are all
predators which is kind of interesting
they are being welcomed but you should
have appearance they've been missed and
counter-intuitively when you bring back
the predator says it actually increases
rather than reduces the diversity of the
underlying ecosystem often yeah
generally predators in large animals in
in large animals and large animals of
the sharp teeth and claws are turning
out to be highly important for a really
rich ecosystem which maybe brings us to
the this rather more dramatic rewilding
project that you've got yourself
involved in why would someone want to
bring back these terrifying woolly
mammoths mm-hmm Asian elephants are the
closest relative
achieve the woolly mammoths and about
same size genetically very close they
diverged quite recently in an
evolutionary history the Asian elephants
are closer to avoid mammoths than they
are to African elephants but they're
close enough to African elephants that
they have successfully hybridized so
we're working with George Church at
Harvard who's already moved the genes
for four major traits from the now well
preserved and well studied genome of the
woolly mammoth
thanks to so-called ancient DNA analysis
and in the lab he has moved those genes
into living Asian elephant cell lines
where they're taking up their proper
place thanks to CRISPR I mean they're
not shooting the genes in like you did
with genetic engineering now with CRISPR
you're editing basically one allele in
replacing the place of another allele so
you're now getting basically Asian
elephant
germline cells that are effectively in
terms of the traits that you're going
for to be comfortable in the Arctic
getting them in there so we go through
the process of getting that through a
surrogate mother Asian elephant mother
you can get a proxy as it's being called
by conservation biologists of the woolly
mammoth that is effectively a hairy
curly trunked asian elephant that is
perfectly comfortable in the subarctic
now it's the case so media people say
how do you got to get on there and Asian
elephants they don't like snow right
well it turns out they do like to know
there's someone in Ontario Zoo that have
made snow balls bigger than people I
just love taking a little by the trunk
you can starve a little thing and roll
it and make it bigger and then if you'll
say yeah but it's 22 months of gestation
it would be kind of you know this kind
of cross species cloning is tricky
business anyway are you going to lose
some of the surrogate Asian elephant
mothers and the church verses that's
where I will do an artificial uterus and
grow them that way and people yeah yeah
next century maybe accept the news came
out this week in nature that there is
now an artificial uterus in which
they've grown a lamb to four weeks and
that's halfway through its gestation
period so this stuff is moving right
along but why should we want a world
where we picture a world where there are
thousands of these things
thundering across Siberia is that a
better world potentially it's I mean the
great there's three groups basically
working on the woolly mammoth
seriously the revive and restore were
kind of in the middle there's George
Church and a group at Harvard they're
doing the genetics in the lab and then
there's a amazing old scientist named Z
moth in who works in northern Siberia
and his son Nikita who's bought into the
system and they are surrogate and Nikita
seem off have been 25 years creating
what they call Pleistocene Park which is
a place and a really tough part of
Siberia that is
pure tundra and the research that's been
done shows that there's probably 1/100
of the animals on the landscape there
that there used to be like that earlier
image we saw lots of animals now there's
almost none Tundra is mostly Moss and
then there's the boreal forest and
that's the way it is folks it's just a
few animals there so we brought in a lot
of grazing animals plus musk ox yoke
Rudy and horses they're bringing some
bison bringing some more now and put
them into the density if they used to be
and grasslands are made by grazers so
these animals are they're grazing away
and they're doing a couple of things
first of all they're turning the tundra
of the moss back into grassland
grassland fixes carbon tundra in a
warming world is thawing and releasing a
lot of carbon dioxide and also methane
so already you know in their little 25
square miles that are doing a climate
stabilization thing part of that story
though is the boreal forest is very
absorbent to sunlight even in the winter
and snow is on the ground and the way
the mammoth steppe which used to wrap
all the way around the North Pole
there's a lot of landmass around the
North Pole that was all this grasslands
and a step was magnificent probably one
of the most make most productive biomes
in the world the biggest biome in the
world
the forest part of it right now
Sergei seamoth and Nikita go out with
this military tank they got for nothing
and they knocked down the trees and
that's a bore and it's tiresome and as
Sergei says and they make no dung which
by the way these bigger animals do
including mammoths so man that's become
what conservation biologists called an
umbrella species that's an exciting
animal pandas in China or wherever that
the excitement that goes on of making
life good for that animal is making a
habitat an ecosystem which is good for a
whole lot of creatures and plants and as
ideally kids to the point of being self
managing where the conservation
biologist can back off and say all we
got to do is keep out the destructive
invasives and this thing can just cook
so there's many other species that
you're dreaming of dear extinct ting at
some point but I think what what I'd
actually like to move on to is the
decider you talked about how you know
mammoths might help green Siberia in a
sense and or at least yeah not I'm not
talking about tropical rainforests but
but this question of greening the planet
you've thought about a lot and that the
traditional story is that you know
deforestation is is is one of the most
awful curses of modern times and that
it's it's a huge contributor to try to
climate change and then you went and
sent me this graph yo this map
what is this map global greening the
thing to do with any narrative that you
get from headlines and from short news
stories is to look for what else is
going on
and look for what Marc Andreessen calls
a narrative violation so the narrative
and Al Gore is of you know a master of
putting it out there is that there's
this civilization threatening climate
change coming on very rapidly we have to
cease all production extra production of
greenhouse gases especially co2 as soon
as possible otherwise we're in deep deep
trouble all of that is true but it's not
the whole story
and the whole story is more interesting
than these fragmentary stories plants
love co2 what plants are made of is co2
Plus water via sunshine and so in in
many greenhouses industrial dust
realized greenhouses they add co2
because the plants turn that at plant
matter so the studies have been done
with satellites and other things and
what you're seeing here is a graph of
over the last 33 years or so there's 14%
more leaf action going on there's that
much more biomass that's that much more
when ecologist called primary production
there's that much more life happening
thanks to climate change thanks to all
of our got in coal plants ends whoa
what's going on here well by the way
production goes up of this there is this
is a partial counter to the increase of
co2 because a lot there's that much more
plant that is sucking it down into plant
matter some of that then decays and goes
right back up but some of it is going
down into roots and going into the soil
and staying there so these counter
things are part of what you need to bear
in mind and if the deeper story is that
thinking about and dealing with and
engineering climate is a pretty complex
process it's like medicine yeah you're
ours again tweaking around the system to
see what makes an improvement and then
do enough more of the at receipt still
getting better oh that's an outback off
half a truck but wouldn't might some
people say look not all green is created
equal you possibly what we're doing is
they're trading off the magnificence of
the rainforest and all that diversity
for I don't know green pond scum or
grass or something like that this
particular study turned out every form
of plant is increasing now what's
interestingly left out of this study is
what the hell's going on in the oceans
primary production in the oceans the
biota of the oceans mostly microbial
what they're up to is probably the most
important thing they're the ones that
create the atmosphere that we're happily
breathing and they're not part of the
study this is one of the things that
James Lovelock has been assisting it's
basically our knowledge of the oceans
especially of ocean life is
fundamentally vapor this says so we're
in the process of finding out by
inadvertent and bad geoengineering of
too much co2 in the atmosphere find out
what is the ocean doing with that well
the ocean with the extra heat is
swelling up that's most of where we're
getting the sea level rise and there's a
lot more coming with more global warming
we're getting terrible harm to some of
the coral reefs like off of Australia
great reef there's just you know a lot
of bleaching from overheating and this
is why I am Danny Hillis our previous
session on the main stage was saying
what geoengineering is worth
experimenting with enough to see that it
works to see if we can buy time on the
warming aspect of all of this
tweek this system with small but usable
research and then see if we should do
more than three okay so this is what
we're gonna talk about for the last few
minutes it's such an important
discussion first what I'm just gonna
show like this book was just published
by Eve all her Ari is basically saying
you know the next evolution of humans is
to become as gods I think he did you
talk to him and you've probably finished
the book I haven't finished it yet where
does she come out I mean it's it's it's
a pretty radical view he thinks that we
will completely remake ourselves using
data using bioengineering to become
completely new creatures that have kind
of superpowers and and that there will
be you know huge inequality and you know
but we're about to write a very radical
brand new chapter of history but that's
what that's what he believes is she
nervous about that I forget he's he is
nervous about it but but I think he also
likes provoking people and you nervous
about that I'm nervous about that but I
mean I'm you know with so much at Ted
I'm I'm excited and nervous and I'd the
optimist in me as trying hard to lean
towards the this is also a really
exciting well the sort of responsible
part of me is saying but maybe we should
be a little bit careful at you know as
to how we think of it that's your secret
sauce isn't it for the yeah there's a
nervous and excited so it's also a
recipe for being a little bit
schizophrenic but he didn't quote you
what I thought was an astonishing
statement that you made back in oh we
don't have that but that right back in
the original Whole Earth Catalog you
ended it with with this this powerful
phrase so you know we are as gods and
might as well get good at it and then
more recently you've you've upgraded
that statement I want wait to talk about
this philosophy well one of the things
I'm learning is documentation is better
than memory by far and one of the things
I've learned from the somebody I
actually I got on Twitter changed my
life Ryan hasn't forgiven me yet and I
took ownership of this phrase when
somebody quoted
somebody else said oh by the way that
isn't what you originally wrote in that
1st 1968 holder Kellogg you wrote we are
as gods and might as well get used to it
I've forgotten that entirely the stories
these goddamn stories the stories we
tell ourselves become lies over time so
documentation helps cut through it
didn't move on to we are Scots and Magus
might as well get good at it and that
was the Whole Earth Catalog by the time
I was doing a book called whole earth
discipline and eco pragmatist manifesto
and in light of climate change and
basically saying we are as gods in half
too good we are with God's and have to
get good at it
so so so talk about that because because
you know the psychological reaction to
so many people on any as soon as you
talk about geoengineering is that the
last thing they believe is that humans
should be God some of them for religious
reasons but most just for humility
reasons that the systems are too complex
we should not be dabbling that way well
this is the Greek narrative about hubris
and once you start getting really sure
of yourself you wind up sleeping with
your mother
I did not expect this you would say that
and you know that's the end of our story
the hubris is a really important
cautionary tale to awes have at hand and
I mean one of the lines I've kept for
myself is every day I ask myself how
many things I am dead wrong about and
I'm a scientist by training and getting
to work with scientists these days which
is pure joy and science is organized
skepticism so you're always insisting
that you know even when something looks
pretty good you maintain a full set of
knowledge suspicions about whether it's
as good as it looks but what else is
going on so this what else is going on
query that I think is how you get away
from fake news and it's not necessarily
real news but it
welcome Li more complex news you're
trying to take on but coming back to the
application that's just for the
environment I mean it's it seems like
the philosophy of this is that whether
we like it or not we already dominating
so many aspects of what happens on
planets so and we're doing it
unintentionally so we we we really
should start doing it intentionally what
what would it look like to start getting
good at being a god what how should we
start doing that are there small-scale
experiments or systems we can nudge and
play with how on earth do we think about
it
the mantra that sort of freed me from
total allegiance to Buckminster Fuller
was a Gregory Bateson Gregory Bateson
was
ologist and anthropologist and biologist
and psychologist and many other things
and he was he looked at how systems
basically look at themselves and that is
I think part of how you want to always
be looking at things that what I like
about David Keith's approach to
geoengineering you don't just halt often
do it
David Keith's approach and this is what
Danny Hillis was talking about earlier
is that you do it really really
incremental you do some stuff to tweak
the system see how it responds that
tells you something about this is it
that's responding to the fact that
people say quite rightly what are we
talking about here we don't understand
how the climate system that works
you can't engineer a system you don't
understand and david says well that
certainly applies to a human body and
yet medicine goes ahead and we're kind
of glad that it has the way you engineer
a system that is so large and complex
that you can't completely understand it
is you tweak it and this is a kind of an
anti hubristic approach this is you know
try a little bit here back the hell off
if it's an issue expanded if it seems to
go okay meanwhile have other paths going
forward this is the whole argument for
diversity and dialogue and all these
other things and the things that we're
hearing about earlier with Sebastian so
the non hubristic approach is looking
for social license which is a
terminology that i think is a good one
of including society and
in these interesting problematic deep
issues that they get to have a pretty
good idea and have people that they
trust paying close attention to the
sequence of experiments is going for the
dialogue the public dialogue that's as
it's going for which is more public than
ever which is fantastic hmm
and you feel your way you just lose your
way along and this is the muddle through
approach that has worked pretty well so
far
and the reason this a bastion and I are
optimistic is we agreed people like
Steven Pinker the better angels of our
nature and you know so far so good now
that cannot change but you can build a
lot on that sense of things are capable
of getting better figure out the tools
that made that happen and apply those
further that's the story so I think on
that optimistic note we're actually
going to wrap up I am in awe of how you
oh you always are willing to challenge
yourself and other people and I feel
like this this recipe for never allowing
yourself to be too certain is so
powerful I've I want to learn it more
for myself and it's been very insightful
and inspiring actually listening to you
today well so Stewart Brand thank you
thank you so much thank you